bene da tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi sono registra a
sistema le volte mi capita fine video di
controllare se finiscono vito spero che
mi sia piaciuto la chiudo
non stavo registrando quello devo rifare
tutto e meglio accorgersene prima la via
secondo ragazzi che sono molto
emozionato perché oggi giochiamo a favor
required senza la mia webcam aspetti che
compaiono non so se vi ricordate spero
di sì perché una pietra miliare del
gaming questo gioco e dagli stessi
creatori di solarkey face of love
incontro fare perché se guardate credo
sia degli stessi creatori perché i
personaggi sono molto più simili di
quanto pensiate sono nudi aiuto
l'eau lancio ma come avete giustamente
io sono un maggiordomo che lanciai gli
asciugamani fatti gioco si chiama tower
riquadro fini lancia gli asciugamani
agli uomini nudi sembra mio zio non solo
per i baffi anche per la stazza allora
di aria via via via via via uomini nudi
via delle balle via dalle balle
l'obiettivo di questo gioco e non
scendere con la vita perché ogni volta
che uno di questi topica la vita scende
infatti avere nel 2005 dicevate il mio
dio chissà nel 2019 2020 che videogiochi
che saranno le macchine volanti towel
required via
no no no no aiuto aiuto aiuto nonni
prego via
questa è una scena che su youtube non
posso mettere però non fa niente youtube
non vedrà mai questo video chi se ne
frega i miei cari video buste giove da
questa per capire come funzionava vedo
che ci sono anche dei perk che ci sono
in giro per aumentare la velocità va
bene il tempo si ferma a tempo
fighissimo quindi si fermano loro nel
mentre tu poi lanciate da jacques amani
bellissimo allora ragazzi questo è tower
required io provo a fare del mio meglio
prima era un livello si propone di
andare di bilancio il coso ok ma perché
ci è riuscita quindi dovete andare al
soul uscito capitone minuti lascia
l'asciugamano la domanda che vorrei che
volevo fare anche prima che non ho
capito la risposta uo minuti dove sono
gli asciuga ma dove mi rifiuto di
asciugamani visto che non dovevo
definisco porca vacca è un gioco peggio
this lander me mi fa più paura questo
che carnesi a che che slay andarmene che
tutti gli horror che ho fatto la mia
vita cav h
niente non ci credo sono facendo peggio
di prima ragazzi mio perché mi son
disincastrato gli ominidi quando ci
circondano il casinò gioco è molto
fuorviante via via fuori dalle balle
giorno gli asciugamani aiuto sono un
uomo povero senza niente aiuto stasera
quella roba lì che non poggiava la cassa
va bene lo ha preso la vita mi sono
rifilato bisogno di asciugamani ragazzi
le mie armi aiuto devi correre cori
slogan è castrato uomini non basta
ragazzi veramente difficile ma vi giuro
che impegnandovi già faro mercato però
non li possono accogliere quando casca
non c'è io sopra i quattro mani con 8234
l'ideale stare in un angolo quando
arrivano gli occhi nudi di lanci la roba
perché se sei nell'angolo li vedi tutti
capi non si possono arrivare da dietro e
fare cose che non vorresti che venissero
fatte
andiamo avanti via via via via via via
via via via via via perfetto perché
l'effetto solo 10 sulla
quindi uno come no 3
no dai che gli sprechi porca vacca ma
porca vacca che per 172 ragazzi mise un
po di marco merino da vecchio non vorrei
dire una cagata pro capite che si
sbagliava
mi date c'è un refeel di asciugamani
fatto bene che non si sa ecco infatti
non è quarto
non so dove si trova gli asciugamani
sono calcio dove mi riprendo le
munizioni ma non ho capito quale ai
ragazzi aiuto datemi in punto aiuto
eccolo no 25 non ho capito se dopo un po
cambia il punto sempre quello non lo so
va bene e mettiamoci in un punto e
stiamo bene tutti i bolli prima quello
di prima ci mettiamo qua dovreste
teoricamente essere apposta da 123456
veloce 3568 madonna quanti sono un
abominio ragazzi non ho capito eccolo a
ok vedi che si rifilano quindi sì sì c'è
un punto dove ogni volta cambiando
aspetto la perdita stop lo stopper stop
del tempo bravissimi beccatevi tutti
stesso cavani come se non ci fosse un
domani
madonna porca vacca ragazzi non so se
scegliere questo call of duty zombies e
come sfida è quindi questo ok la
ragazzina molto inquietante prima di
tutto e che sembrano marco marino un po
più 0 è stato da quando aprire la via
fuori dalle balle
mi sto testando la faccia tra l'altro
alcuni porco demonio quanti siete aiuto
l'ho preso e bellissimo che quando
prendi l'asciugamani far rumore come se
avessi equipaggiato un'arma con l'umore
di strano aiuto no no spingi spingi non
buio dello spin 325 ragazzi e un ottimo
punteggio per un gioco così ora sono
sempre più orgoglioso di dove mi sta
portando youtube oggi oggi youtube è
quello che io volevo fare
la grande quando mi chiedevano che cosa
vorresti parla grande lorenzo come
lavoro voglio lanciare l'asciugamano a
mio zio nudo ma questa è la stata la
prima cosa che ho pensato è con
disegnato all'asilo quando lo dicevano
di disegnare che cosa volevo nel futuro
ecco esattamente questo io vorrei questo
tutta la vita
speriamo che la mia vita non mi faccio
mai cattive sorprese di non cambiare mai
la mia direzione di vita perché sono
sicuro di essere nel giusto
perfetto ci vorrebbero essere state fair
dove sono io
vorrebbero esserci oro non ci siete mi
dispiace ragazzi avete un lavoro
differente molto meno bello del mio
perché voi fate e altre cose io faccio
questi giorno che voi non potete fare ma
li faccio io vi preoccupate ragazzi con
diverto anche per voi ma che roba
ma che roba perfetto dividono dipendente
da nessuno ragazzi vede solo la metto
solo dal buon favi che vi porta sempre
contenuti di qualità quale come fatta
bene l'acqua guarda questa andy di rt
funziona bene devo capire un attimo se
il record può essere battibile ma quello
di prima ragazzi vi assicuro che era un
gran bel record e perché infezione 325
no fatto non l'ho neanche preso il cuore
va bene ad altro voi non potete vedere
kakà non potete vedere a quanto sto di
punteggio ma che ci amiamo al canto fra
ma meglio così vorrei se possibile
mettere tante mie facce al posto del
birillo di qualche persona che tanto non
ce l'hanno 260 miri figlio gli
asciugamani e se rischio scafo che
prende il tempo che stalin a fini non lo
prendo credo questo che la più citata ha
detto devo prendere il tempo se non
prendo tempo sono morto perfetto
perfetto perfetto rispetto il tempo al
tempo il tempo tempo ecco qua
ok consob al record perfetto se non è
vero
320 single devo trovare l'altra
cercavano aiuto se ne trova un altro che
non so dove sono ho battuto record
teoricamente però devo trovarlo lì dove
siano ecco li ho trovati ragazzo
prattutto record poi 90 perfetto 3 cesa
nonché successo
ma se vado nella doccia brodo punti
porca vacca a volte dinamiche di gioco
neanche rendete redemption è così tante
complimenti se vado nella doccia per due
punti di niente dobbiamo schivare lucia
ragazzi penso sempre un po agli adulti
no che guardano youtube e di contestarne
funziona questo mondo ma un mestiere 29
diamante le fa dj chelo youtuber di
seguito di tale veniamo questa cosa e
questo mondo delusioni per vediamo
cerchiamo di capire che cosa con aiuti
perché io non capisco sono vecchio no
dicono questo pensate quelli che
guarderanno questo video di l'anno ecco
che cos'era youtuber io non saprei come
spiegarlo vedere
giusto così 475 punti e siamo ancora in
ballo ragazzo ancora eccoli nord kakà
mamma mia cosa un play di punteggio
attenzione 540 dobbiamo prendere io devo
trovare una routine giusta da fare c'è
asciugamani che poi che abbia sempre
posizione quindi non è facile però se
prendo questo più tempo teoricamente
permetto dovete togliere dai via di qua
porca vacca ma che c'era il tempo
stavano fermi ho preso questo mancano
gli asciugamani siamo a 575 ragazzi
ottimo punteggio di daria si
moltiplicano e una specie è veramente
orribile si moltiplicano aiuto
non trovo il tempo non trovo trovo il
tempo per fermarli aiuto aiuto perfetto
veramente notato un sacco via però non
trovo il tempo non [ __ ] sulle
manutenzioni
siamo a 635 ve lo dico io punteggio
sposta un po la testa si vede un'altra
parte
qui ha via via via via che non è vero
ciccio fatta mi sono liberato alla fine
sono vivo sono vivo però sono vivo
bellissimo ce l'ho fatta niente male
ragazzi a persone adulte che sta
lavorando cos'è il mestiere dello
youtuber continuate a fare il suo lavoro
è molto meglio la sicuro che veramente
no no no no no scavalca i no sono
incastrato nella doccia porco demonio
735 niente male ragazzi veramente niente
male questo ragazzi era tawan require
stato molto difficile come il gameplay
richiede abilitato sicuro che nel mondo
del pro gay ming ci sarà spazio anche
per questo i ragazzi vi ringrazio però
che vi sia piaciuto sto trovate
ovviamente un gioco dove sono bravo non
forza mai lasciato argomento mi piace
iscritti al canale sia già dalla
campanelli e ragazzi
mi metto aggiornati sui nuovi video
chiesto e noi come sempre ci rivediamo
ad un prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]